Frédéric Paris et copropriétaire d'une
ferme de 5500 poulets chaque jour à
plusieurs reprises il doit entrer dans
ses bâtiments en respectant des mesures
de sécurité très strictes
à tous les jours qui me permet comme
d'agrandir ma zone propre sa routine est
fastidieuse mais nécessaire le virus de
la grippe aviaire le H5 nne est un tueur
invisible et extrêmement efficace
première étape je vais prendre le savon
je vais nettoyer
physiquement brosser les bottes pour
enlever les matières organiques puis la
boue la saleté des trucs la deuxième
étape après le nettoyage c'est la
désinfection puis il franchit le seuil
de la porte retirer ses bottes enfile
une combinaison stérilisée et finalement
remets une autre paire de bottes
maintenant il peut prendre soin de ses
poules vous avez pas le choix finalement
on a toujours le choix mais il y a des
conséquences coûteuses fâcheuses et très
pénible à vivre avec les choix qu'on
ferait ou les raccourcis qu'on décidera
de prendre depuis 2022 on a recensé plus
de 11000 éclosions de H5 N1 dans le
monde dont 261 au Canada et 47 au Québec
le tiers de nos cas étant survenu depuis
un mois un risque qui est présent on
peut pas l'ignorer puis c'est pour ça
qu'une mobilisation générale de tous les
producteurs et les intervenants du
milieu à chaque éclosion il faut abattre
tous les oiseaux
désinfectés à fond les bâtiments et
compostait les carcasses même les fermes
avicole voisine doivent cesser les
opérations dans un rayon d'un kilomètre
donc toutes les femmes qui se situe dans
ce rayon là ne peuvent pas entrer
d'oiseaux donc peuvent sortir à ce sujet
à des permis peuvent sortir les oiseaux
qui est en production mais peuvent pas
rentrer d'oiseaux supplémentaires
la menace vient surtout des déjections
des grands migrateurs qui survolent les
champs et les bâtiments en route vers le
nord du Québec mais ils ne sont plus les
seuls responsables qui s'est passé l'an
dernier c'est que le niveau de
propagation était suffisamment élevé que
finalement
il y a eu d'autres espèces qui ont été
affectées particulièrement des
carnivores qui peuvent se nourrir des
oiseaux migrateurs la ferme Joël située
à Montérégie se trouve à proximité de
plusieurs zones où il y a eu des
éclosions prenez des personnes qui ont
été infectées qui ont vu le élevage
détruit l'empasser pas très loin d'ici
donc c'est vraiment une menace qui est
très réel qui est quotidienne comme la
production de poulet est concentrée dans
trois régions au Québec les éleveurs
craignent particulièrement les
fermetures en cascade c'était le cas
Valcartier en 2022 lorsque est arrivé
nos premiers cas je dirais de grippe
aviaire qui a touché sur nos secteurs
dans le dindon
donc un premier cas un deuxième donc
nécessairement un chacun des cas
débouler puis il y a eu des impacts sur
les autres depuis l'arrivée du virus au
Québec on a dû abattre autour de 850 000
volailles avec le retour des migrateurs
et la multiplication des éclosions on
entre donc maintenant dans une phase
très délicate pour les élevages on a je
pense en tant que producteur et éleveur
de volaille de toutes les sortes
confondues à prendre à vivre avec ce
nouveau reste là le virus de la grippe
aviaire ben c'est notre covid
en tant qu'elles veulent ici Normandin
Radio-Canada à Sainte-Cécile de Milton